journée mondiale de lutte contre le sida
le 1er décembre et j'accueille donc
jérôme andré bonsoir vous êtes le
président aux hf prévention associations
de prévention comme son nom l'indiqué
base et du côté de villepreux votre
mission organiser des actions
d'information et puis également sur la
transmet à transmission du sida et puis
également présenté les moyens de se
prémunir
on va présenter tout à l'heure aussi les
autotests vous êtes venu avec ce petit
test qui permet en santé encore des
autotests puisque effectivement ses
fonctions avant ce sont des css 2
minutes soit la minute effectivement
pour pouvoir déterminer si l'on est
porteur ou non du vih on va donner
quelques chiffres tout d'abord l'onu
sida a publié son rapport annuel il y à
34 millions d'infection hiv sida dans le
monde dont 5 2 5 millions de nouveaux
cas en france
cent cinquante mille personnes sont
séropositives mais malgré tout on
constate que ça régresse il ya moins de
décès - de contamination également est
ce que c'est une bonne nouvelle malgré
les contaminations sont stables alors on
a effectivement d'entre six et à 8000
personnes qui sont nouvellement
contaminées par an c'est quand même
énorme
cela dit c'est vrai qu'on ne meurt plus
aujourd'hui du sida grâce notamment aux
éleveurs et aux évolutions entre autres
les télés les trithérapies
il ya aujourd'hui beaucoup de
laboratoires qui font des choses très
bien et qui arrive effectivement à
maintenir les gens dans des situations
où il ya de moins en moins d'effets
secondaires et maintenant l'état veut de
plus en plus parler de maladies
chroniques
concernant donc le vih et pour
communiquer pour toujours faire peur
aussi parce qu'il faut faire peur avec
cette maladie ce n'est pas plus
difficile lorsqu'on explique que le sida
arrive on arrive à le faire régresser
ça fait quelques années qu'on ait des
trithérapies qui sont apparus
effectivement pour les personnes
séropositives
on ne meurt plus donc la générosité des
gens s'en ressent et on le voit
notamment à la période du sidaction qui
est en général traditionnellement au
mois de mars
le sidaction qui d'ailleurs reverse 50%
à la recherche 50% aux associations dont
la nôtre et le sidaction qui a
d'ailleurs été vraiment à fer de lance
sur la mise en place des tests rapides
les tests in style entre autres alors
restez bien avec vous verrez tout à
l'heure comment cela fonctionne c'est
c'est très rapide et c'est très simple
journée mondiale de lutte contre le sida
ce 1er décembre avec pour mot d'ordre
objectif zéro zéro nouvelle infection au
vih zéro discrimination et zéro décès
liés au sida est ce que c'est possible
tout simplement belle hélène
c'est l'objectif mais est ce que c'est
possible rapidement toutes les
associations aimerait effectivement
éradiquer cette pandémie on sait que
c'est utopique
cela dit effectivement pour pouvoir
l'éradiquer entre autres il y à des
associations comme la nôtre qui vont au
contact du public
parce qu'en réalité sur cent cinquante
mille personnes séropositives ont
aujourd'hui en france on a quand même 50
mille personnes qui s'ignorent qui sont
séropositifs qui contamine d'autres
personnes par relation sexuelle entre
autres et qui effectivement ne sont pas
au courant de leur séropositivité
d'où l'intérêt des tests rapides la
journée mondiale c'est l'occasion de
parler du sida bien sûr c'est aussi
l'occasion de récolter des fonds vont
nous disiez régulièrement il faut des
fonds pour les associations pour
intervenir sur le terrain on regarde
juste un spot réalisé à l'occasion du
sidaction
nous parlons donc de cette journée
mondiale de mobilisation dans la lutte
contre le sida du 1er décembre avec
l'association hf prévention et on va
s'intéresser à ces tests minutes alors
je parlais tout à l'heure d'autotest ce
n'est pas le cas on peut pas encore le
faire tout seul il faut être accompagné
et les bénévoles de l'association y
participent
vous allez nous expliquer comment cela
fonctionne comment vous intervenez
lorsque vous êtes son terrain que les
gens viennent vous voir
alors déjà elle la différence entre un
autotest et un test minutes c'est
qu'effectivement les personnes sont
formés et habilités à pouvoir discuter
avec les bénéficiaires pouvoir leur
expliquer leur prise de risque négocier
leur prise de risque dans la réduction
donc des risques
d'où l'intérêt de ne pas avoir
d'autotest en tout cas nous c'est notre
c'est notre principe on préfère avoir
des gens formés qui vont être à nous
former à l'annoncé du résultat annoncé à
quelqu'un qu'il est séropositif c'est
pas forcément simple n'est pas
facilement lire au début vous prennent
et aussi les gens effectivement test
pourrait en fonction des réponses qui
vont vous faire forcément être plutôt
positif l'insee l'idée c'est que c'est
un test minute cependant effectivement
il ya toujours une demi heure trois
quarts d'heure une heure on prend le
temps avec les gens parce que c'est
important aussi que eux puissent
prennent en charge donc leur prévention
d'où le fait aussi qu'on distribue toute
l'année des préservatifs en trop sur les
lieux de rencontres extérieures concon
visite il ya des gens par exemple qui ne
vont pas au bout du dispositif quand
vous leur annoncer voile à l'issue du
test éventuellement vous pourriez vous
rendre compte que vous êtes porteur du
vih
exactement il ya aussi des gens que nous
on refuse c'est à dire qu'on leur dit
voilà on ne trouve que vous n'êtes pas
suffisamment aujourd'hui prêt à entendre
le résultat qu'ils soient positifs ou
négatifs et on leur propose plutôt de
s'orienter vers un centre de dépistage
anonyme et gratuit qui reste donc la
méthode la plus classique est la plus
traditionnelle donc là comment cela
fonctionne alors le testeur rapide c'est
relativement simple
donc ce sont donc des tests in ch'ti
avec une membrane qui est donc ici on a
donc eu un bras nom qui est donc
présente alors dans une petite coupole
avec derrière un tampon tout simplement
on va piquer la personne donc c'est
moins facile pour moi de me le faire
c'est bien un autotest voilà merci l'as
vous pestez sur vous mais c'était pas un
autre test on va donc récupérer tout
bêtement une goutte de sang de la
personne
alors il y a effectivement donc on dit
une goutte mais c'est plus c'est plus
pour la forme mais sinon effectivement
donc on récupère un petit peu de sang
jusque au très haut niveau donc de la
pipette
encore une fois ce n'est pas simple de
se le faire soi même
alors essayez ce qui effectivement je le
redis ce ne sont pas des tests que l'on
se procure pour le faire soi même il
faut être accompagné et c'est notamment
le travail dash est prévu c'est le
travail des chefs france on est formés
habilitée par le ministère donc de la
santé pour ça c'est important de le dire
c'est est aussi sont financés par l'état
et les pouvoirs publics entre autres
aussi le sidaction c'est important aussi
de le rappeler ça permet effectivement
que les pouvoirs publics puissent
prendre donc la mesure de la pandémie et
puisse effectivement ils répondent alors
là on a donc le flat coin le flat coin
ça va effectivement servir à pouvoir
séparer
donc les anticorps ce flacon je vais le
verset donc directement dans la coupole
comme ceux ci comme ont aperçu tout à
l'air voilà voilà donc là je verse
l'intégralité du flacon très rapidement
on s'aperçoit que le flacon est passé en
totalité dans donc la membrane et c'est
cette membrane qui va révéler
effectivement la séropositivité ou non
de la personne grâce entre autres aux
flacons deux come all ye c'est assez
simple d'où le fait que des animateurs
de prévention et des bénévoles donc très
rapidement sont formés donc à
l'utilisation
le laboratoire qui a mis en place
effectivement ces tests est un
laboratoire canadien s'était sont
utilisés depuis quelques années entre
autres aux états unis et on a donc
ensuite le flacon 3 qui est un une
éclaircie soeur tout bêtement et à
partir de là nos animateurs de
prévention sont capables de dire si
effectivement la personne est
séropositive ou non puisqu'on a donc le
résultat immédiatement j'attends juste
que le liquide soit sa couleur ce sont
des avocats très simplement on a en fait
la membrane qui elle toujours blanc
et on a donc un point pour résultat
positif
un point pour résultat négatif alors là
on ne voit pas forcément donc à la
caméra mais effectivement le fait de
pouvoir leur montrer ce qu'ont expliqué
donc directement aux gens on a
effectivement deux points si la personne
est séropositive
un seul point c'est la personne et ses
ouailles hâtives et ça ça change la
donne
parce qu'effectivement on peut nous bien
mieux promouvoir le dépistage comme
étant un outil et dire aux gens voilà
maintenant effectivement vous êtes
séropositif et là en l'occurrence il y à
un traitement et on peut les mettre dans
le circuit donc dans l'accès aux soins
et en cas donc de ces renégats de
séronégativité c'est important aussi
qu'on les redirige vers les centres de
dépistage anonyme et gratuit parce que
outre le vih
souvent les gens ne vont pas se faire
dépister parce qu'ils ont peur du
résultat du vih
on a aussi toutes les infections
sexuellement transmissibles et je pense
par exemple aux hépatites et c'est vrai
que pour le coup il ya quand même une
vraie pandémie au niveau du vih mais il
ya aussi de grave problématique au
niveau donc
des ist et entre autres donc des
infections sexuellement transmissibles y
voit quelques images en petite vidéo
réalisée et qui permet de voir comment
cela fonctionne pour ce test ce test
minutes
une question qu'on n'a pas abordé c'est
gratuit si on vient vous voir c'est un
des points alors nous effectivement
c'est totalement gratuit puisque
effectivement c'est financé par le
ministère de la santé
et vous pouvez donc venir donc nous
rencontrer nous on nous sommes hébergés
donc nous sommes nationale la plateforme
ile de france ouest est hébergée à
l'institut de promotion de la santé
grâce notamment aux cons à la communauté
d'agglomération de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines communauté qui
a d'ailleurs très envie de mettre en
place ce style de deux tests directement
donc sur saint quentin
que ce soit au travers d'actions on
l'espère peut-être un institut de
promotion de la santé la cie
concrètement demain ou même le 1er
décembre à l'occasion de la journée
mondiale de lutte contre le sida on
souhaitait effectuer ce test et et
rencontrer l'association
alors vous venez effectivement nous nous
voir directement à l'institut de
promotion de la santé
nous avons donc nos locaux là bas par
ailleurs on ne fait pas encore les tests
là bas mais cela dit ça va venir très
rapidement c'est pour les jours qui
viennent et de toute façon on pourra
donc vous proposer des préservatifs de
la documentation de l'information sachez
aussi que l'institut de promotion de la
santé fait un stand donc à l'occasion du
1er décembre à la médiathèque de saint
quentin en yvelines parce que bien
évidemment nous parlions de ce test mais
il reste nécessaire indispensable de se
protéger bien évidemment le préservatif
qui est l'unique le meilleur des moyens
de se protéger
ces tests permettent de toucher aussi un
autre public
exactement qui ne viennent pas se faire
dépister vous lisez tout à l'heure il ya
des gens qui sont porteurs du vih et qui
ne le savent pas qui ne se font pas
dépister
souvent les gens ont la peur de
connaître le résultat est encore cet
après midi nous étions sur un lieu de
rencontres extérieures et la personne
nous disait moi je ne vais pas à
l'hôpital parce que j'ai la peur du
médecin là en l'occurrence il rencontre
des animateurs de prévention ou des
bénévoles qui ne sont pas forcément donc
des médecins et du coup on n'attend pas
que ce soit eux qui viennent à nous
comme un petit peu le font les cdag
c'est bien normal c'est nous qui allons
au contact du public
c'est comme ça que nous passons
régulièrement dans les unit
merci tu es ou encore sur donc des
foyers migrants foyer de jeunes
travailleurs ou autre pourquoi pas les
missions locales si elles l'acceptent
mais c'est vrai que du coup nous avons
pour vocation nous d'aller vers le
public et notamment sur les lieux de
rencontres extérieures
est ce qu'il y a en moins de vigilance
est ce que vous êtes moins vigilants
c'est l'une des questions que nous avons
posées aujourd'hui à l'occasion de cette
journée mondiale de lutte contre le sida
j'ai l'impression ne peut pas être
touchés en fait il peut ne pas être
concerné j'ai ma copine après donc
c'est différent mais sinon sinon je me
protège protège autant qu'avant et je
vais continuer à me protéger comme ça
mais je pense qu'il ya des gens qui sont
plus
concerné par ça que d'autres qui se
sentent plus concernés que d'autres y en
a qui n'ont rien à faire je pense que ça
n'arrive qu'aux autres et en a qui sont
pas concernés quand on a pas mais les
mêmes partenaires
bah c'est bien se protéger bas pour
pavois des plusieurs maladies à part des
le sida les campagnes de prévention soit
son moins audible qu'avant soit les
jeunes peut-être l'impression qu'il y en
a moins qu'avant ça c'est vrai vous avez
l'impression vous qui êtes sur le
terrain le sentiment que les jeunes en
tout cas où les moins jeunes sont moins
vigilants
qu'est-ce qu'elle protège moi alors
c'est juste affligeant c'est à dire que
nous on passe régulièrement dans les
universités on va de temps en temps en
lycée cfa et on se rend compte
qu'aujourd'hui beaucoup de jeunes fondu
sans capote c'est à dire
qu'effectivement il on a beaucoup de
rapports à risque
c'est juste très inquiétant pour nous
non seulement sur le vih mais aussi sur
toutes les infections sexuellement
transmissibles et honnêtement j'ai du
boulot merci germandrée d'achève
prévention journée de lutte contre le
sida le 1er décembre je vous retrouve
demain en direct à 18h avec de nouveaux
invités je vous souhaite une excellente
soirée